[Musik]
und im wallis strand über 40 kilometer
weiter bei einer sandstrand
hier ist das mehrweg nirgendwo sonst an
deutschen küsten krachen die wellen mit
solcher wucht auf land
genau deshalb lieben winzer für dieses
revier
die luft ist besonders gesund die
brandung versprüht feinste tröpfchen
voller meeres mineralien der wind lässt
den alltag einfach weg
quer über den dünen führen euch wander
und radwege an die ostseite der insel
[Musik]
es ist die sanftere hier erstreckt sich
das wattenmeer
[Musik]
die gezeiten bestimmen das leben alle
sechs stunden geht oder kommt das mehr
als besonders schützenswerte natur
landschaft gehört das wattenmeer seit
2009 zum unesco welterbe mitsamt seinen
bewohnern
[Musik]
friesisches ambiente findet ihr in den
zehn inseldörfern
der ort kampf steht für luxus mit seinen
edel boutiquen ist der laufsteg der
schönen und reichen zu jeder jahreszeit
schuld ist die modernste der deutschen
nordsee in sind
ganz traditionell das friesendorf
zeitung
die meisten häuser stammen aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert uns im kapitäns
häuser im heimatmuseum erfahrt ihr wie
die menschen früher auf sylt gelebt
haben die banken seefahrer und walfänger
kapitäne und fischer
bis so gegen ende des 19 jahrhunderts
der tourismus kam und auf der
fischerinsel eine urlaubsinsel wurde
[Musik]
wenn kinder auf sylt kann jeder sein
ganz persönliches highlight finden
irgendwo zwischen meer und watt luxus
und friesischer gemütlichkeit